No
Tap yes or no,
yes.
The future linaric Center Engross
yes or no?
Yes.
Which linguistic model do you choose,
b or d?
D
would be in favor of 1 wind farm
in your municipality of residence?
I understand that yes.
Which prioritizes sovereignty,
b care or c economy?
Priority should be given to 1 set of the 3 things
because it is fundamental
to meet 1 Good care policy and 1 policy
economic,
to have its own capabilities.
Cell phones at the Cole
must be banned?
I believe that every Center
must have the capacity to decide
what is best in terms of age
and students.
Do you consider that Donostia
need 1 new multipurpose pavilion?
I think so.
Would you take away the home purchase deduction?
to encourage renting?
No?
I think they are compatible things,
too.
Housing purchase
needs your deduction and the rent as well
needs your deduction.
Equality
considers that parity quotas must be established
in party executives?
I think we have 1 equality law
that already eh indicates that positive discrimination is necessary
the presence of women
in the games,
in the public administration,
In the company,
we must move in this direction.
And finally,
do you have private or health insurance,
don't you?